in our present world of fake news i
noticed that a lot of people
don't know how to read the news even
people who
know that the media very often lie to
you they're very often dishonest
they still don't know what to look for
what should throw up a little warning
sign to say
maybe this article is not totally on the
level even i've got conservative
relatives
trump supporters all this but they still
believe the media because the media are
very good at what they do
that's how they've been able to
establish this kind of cultural hegemony
so it's very difficult to tell what's
real
what's not fortunately i am a seasoned
expert in
sifting through fake news that is my job
i do it i do it every day and i try to
figure out what's real and what's not
there was a story i saw the other day
about laverne cox laverne cox is an
actor who identifies as an actress
and an alleged transphobic attack that
just occurred on laverne cox
and so you're reading through it and you
don't know i'm not going to say it's
totally not true
i'm not going to say it's totally true
you've got to figure out what the
warning signs are you've got to you've
got to
place your bets it's all about rest
before we get started this video is
sponsored by
my bookie the best place to bet on
sports and political events
of all kinds more from them later now i
am going to
see if i can bet whether or not this is
a real story or fake story with all
these guys you know you think of brian
stelter you think of
don lemon you think of chris cuomo all
these fake journalists out there
you want to be able to judge how
reliable a story is so i will rate how
many lemons this story gets at the end
title laverne cox reveals she and a
friend were victims of a transphobic
attack the phrase transphobic is in
there so immediately you know okay
transphobic this is a made-up term it's
just a way to castigate people who don't
believe that men can become women as
bigots
so already this is from such a radical
ideological leftist perspective
i'm already skeptical of what this
person's going to put out
laverne cox is thankfully safe at home
after a terrifying attack this weekend
the orange
is the new black star was walking in
la's griffith park on sunday
with a friend and the two were
approached by a man okay just just that
very first sentence though
after a terrifying attack when you start
to see lots of adjectives pop
up rather than just the facts right
rather than just the nouns and the verbs
and you see those adjectives especially
right from the top you know okay there's
a
strong perspective coming in here this
is not just a rundown of what happened
they're trying to give you a narrative
okay the man was looking to attack cox
and thankfully it's the second use of
thankfully this is not very good pros
another key that maybe this person isn't
the best most objective reporter
thankfully her friend stepped in and
de-escalated the situation but not until
things got physical
cox says the attack was understandably
scary triggering nothing new
for anyone who is transgender so then
you're establishing the premise
that transgender people are under
attack in america and they're constantly
the victims
of crime we'll get to the real
statistics on this in just a second
cox says she and her friend were walking
through the park
when the man approached them and
aggressively asked for the time
speaking to her followers on instagram
live
cox said that the man then tried to
spook her by asking guy or girl
cox said her friend replied f off and
the man responded by physically
attacking her friend
physically attacking this is very broad
how did he physically attack the friend
did he punch
did he jab did he pull out some kind of
weapon did he
what was the physical attack specificity
here is going to be
helpful in determining whether or not
this happened because specificity means
you can hear the claim and then
adjudicate how reasonable that was
cox quickly grabbed her phone to call
9-1-1 and said that the incident was
thankfully it was thankfully again
that's weird
over before she was able to finish
dialing noting that her friend was able
to de-escalate the attack and prompt the
man to leave them alone so hold on
this is the first part where i say this
doesn't quite add up the man comes up
and he's asked the time and then he's
being rude and they get into an
altercation
he starts physically attacking this
friend so laverne cox pulls out the
phone that takes
one second to do pulled out my phone and
has to dial three buttons
and by the way 911 on the iphone which i
assume is is the phone that lover and
cox has
you just click like one button right
just click it swipe and it's on
in that amount of time because lauren
cox never did call 9-1-1
we're to believe that there was a
physical altercation and then the friend
de-escalated the situation such that
laverne cox no longer felt
that he had to call all in the amount of
time it would take to swipe
or to click three buttons on a phone
that time scale doesn't add up to me
this dude was looking for trouble
because i happened to be a trans person
in public
said cox adding that she was going to
call her therapist
to help her process the trauma that's
all it felt like this isn't shocking to
me obviously this is my life i've dealt
with this
a lot but it never fails to be shocking
i guess
i've been trans my whole life i've been
harassed and bullied my whole life none
of this is new
but it's still just kind of like why do
you need to be aggressive
okay so now you've got this whole life
narrative it's not just about this
incident it's this is always happening
to me i've got to talk to my therapist
because i've been working through all of
these traumas and these psychological
problems for a long time now
it's it's all about sort of me and my
journey and my narrative
again raises questions by the way it's
betting season over at my bookie
as if you were not already way into
politics right now with my bookie
you can bet on things like the 2024 u.s
presidential election winner
will it be aoc will it be ted cruz will
it be kanye west will it be elon musk
you can place your bets now nothing
makes an event more exciting than
putting
some money on it with sports and
election season in full swing now is the
time
to try your hand whether you've been
betting for years or you're ready to
play for the first time my bookie is
your go-to this season
biggest online selection of bets and
props my bookie has made it simple
to win and easy to withdraw your cash
i'm actually
heading out to go see my friend senator
cruz for our uh
our podcast together so you know maybe
i'll have to make it interesting maybe
i'll put a couple bets there
head on over to mybookie to create an
account just use the promo code knowles
to claim your 100 deposit match all the
way up to a thousand dollars that means
if you put a hundred dollars in they'll
give you another hundred dollars it is
easy
and a great way to jumpstart your
bankroll nfl nba mlb everything else
they've got it all on tap
it's never too late to get started on
your winning season only at my bookie
okay then posts this video syllabus
posts a story about this right away
cox recorded the video only moments
after returning home and was still in
the same outfit she was wearing
while walking in the park which
consisted of a black hoodie black yoga
pants and a black mask okay hold on
here you've got this image painted that
this person is wearing all black and
covering his face and yet he's
recognized
from far away from somebody now it could
be the case
i couldn't pick laverne cox out of a
lineup i don't i don't really even know
what he looks like
but it could be the case that this
person this
attacker saw that this is just a
transvestite you know so
maybe he didn't recognize the actor but
he recognized this as a transvestite and
i'm gonna go harass a transvestite but
maybe not i don't know i mean assuming
that laverne cox has had enough work
done that
he looks like a woman and he's covered
up completely you know
all wearing all black and a black mask i
just i just don't really buy the black
hoodie so is the hood over his
head maybe i mean if that were the case
who would know you wouldn't even know
that someone is
trying to look like a woman or trying to
look like a man that part raises a lot
of suspicion
to me the actor said she began blaming
that's kind of interesting
the actor because now actresses straight
actresses actresses who know that
they're actresses want to go by the male
term actor
and laverne cox who is a man who is
identifying as a woman
wants to go by the mail term actor as
well very confusing ideology
the actor said she began blaming herself
for the attack and looking for ways that
it could have been avoided
before remembering that what had just
happened was in no way her fault
we were walking in the park we weren't
doing anything it's just
it's not safe in the world so that's the
problem that they're existing in the
world no
further description of this alleged
attack the attack against cox comes here
we go
here we go this is also coincidental the
attack against cox comes just days after
the annual trans day of remembrance the
human rights campaign reports that 2020
has seen a rise in transgender or gender
non-conforming people
being fatally shot or killed by other
violent means black or
latinx transgender women represent the
largest
number of victims okay and there is the
there is the political call to action
so there is the agenda right there is
the claim that broadly speaking
transgender people men who believe that
they're women or vice versa but mostly
men who believe that they're women
are being slaughtered they're being
murdered at very very high rates and
it's just because
they have this peculiar sexual identity
that is not true the number of
transgender people or gender
non-conforming so people who either
think they're the opposite sex or that
they have no sex at all
who have been killed in the united
states this year according to cnn is 37
not 37 000 not 3 700 not
370 37 according to the national weather
service
49 people each year are killed by
lightning strikes
there are more people significantly more
people each year
on average who are killed by being
struck by lightning
then are killed for being transgender
having this kind of view that you're the
opposite sex that you are
just to put the numbers in perspective
further the number of
people who identify as the other sex who
are killed among them
60 of them according to the reuters
foundation news 60 of them are
prostitutes
not saying that you know it's it's fine
to
kill prostitutes what i'm saying is
prostitutes are already more likely to
be victims of crimes
so you can't just say it's because of
the way that they identify their sex
no statistically speaking it might have
something to do with their line of work
the situations
that they're in the neighborhoods that
they're in whatever right there are
these other factors
as well i'm not saying this didn't
happen maybe it happened
maybe something happened i'm not saying
it's a full jessie smallette
made-up story it does seem a little
suspect
the details certainly seem suspect that
the fact that it comes a couple days
after the
transgender liturgical feast day you
know the transgender day that's
celebrated in the popular culture
is a little bit suspect the timing of
you know it
laverne cox couldn't dial 9-1-1 in the
time that apparently there was a
physical attack that took place and a
de-escalation and the guy went away and
they felt safe
that seems a little bit suspect to me as
well and then the political tie-in
on all of the the story seems a little
suspect and then the fact that it takes
place in hollywood show business
where there are certainly hoaxes and
fanciful things that come in
also make me suspect on a scale of
0 to 10 lemons you know 10 lemons being
just completely unreliable
probably fake news zero lemons being
maybe it's reliable i don't know i mean
i would probably
say that my skepticism puts it at about
a
five or six lemon category so i think
maybe something like this did happen i'm
not saying that nothing like this
happened
but that the way that the narrative is
being presented is quite dishonest
that's just my take that's how i would
read this news story and if i were
i guess as i'm doing right now if i were
to relate this news story
i would have a healthy dose of
skepticism and i would i would
get the facts on the ground that we can
establish and i'd say that only really
makes up about
10 of the story and then it seems like
90 is this whole political narrative
and the political narrative is not just
suspect it's it's downright
incorrect it's dishonest the idea that
there's a massacre going on of
of people because of their sexual
identity in this country it's just not
true
that that does not happen the numbers
don't back it up the facts don't back it
up that aspect
lots and lots of lemons with that now if
you happen to stumble upon any other
very biased poorly written news articles
or stories that may or may not be fake
news
please post them in the comments section
we'll get to them next time
[Music]
[Music]